about to go live everyone so give me
just a moment
right and
hello everyone welcome to our digital
marketing master class
google changes affecting digital
marketing
with matt bailey the founder and
president of sitelogic marketing and a
digital marketing faculty member at
simplylearn
before we get started i would like to
remind you of how to use webex controls
please place your questions for matt in
the q a box we'll be able to take some
of those at the end in the q a section
of the presentation
and
if you do use the chat make sure you
address it to all panelists
rather than host presenter we will
not see it if you just uh
use a default host or host presenter
so all panelists for the chat
and
we are going to be doing
a few polls today
so i would like to um
start with this very simple one
which is
how much work experience do you have
if you're
watching through streaming on youtube or
linkedin please put your answers in the
chat
the second question of this poll
talks about how you're feeling today
we've been doing that
since the pandemic started check in with
people
got about 20 seconds left on the pull
okay get your answers in please
right
and
you can see we have a pretty even
distribution of people
by
years of experience
with a good representation of people
both at the
very experienced end and at the
junior end
so
that will tailor his presentation to
cover all of that
and both segments of the audience but
the nice thing to see is that
um
vast majority of you are feeling well or
doing
better than well so
we hope that this
presentation will
brighten your mood
if you're not in that category
with that
let me
introduce matt
and matt bailey is the president of
sitelogic
um
he's a digital marketing instructor for
the direct marketing association new
york city
uh instructor for the omcp
and author of several books including
internet marketing an hour a day wired
to be wowed and teach an old dog new
tricks
so we're very proud to have him as part
of our
digital marketing faculty and we're very
lucky to have him here today
hi matt
i think you're on mute
how are you doing today stuart
great and i'm gonna
let you
have screen privileges so that you can
present to us
all right hopefully everything is up and
viewable
and i'm also just you know i'm gonna
turn on the chat box here i'm not gonna
be able to look at it all the time but
if you have any questions and would like
to interact as we go along that's a
great place to do it and uh hope you are
ready to cover some of the changes that
google has been making
and they're around two areas number one
location and number two language and
around those two areas google has been
doing a lot of implementing and using
their machine learning in order to
change how the results render and how to
determine who gets what results so
that's what we're going to cover in this
hours the changes to location the
changes to language processing how
they're implementing machine learning
and the impact on keywords
and so that is going to be key as you
move forward especially in optimization
but also in paid search there are a lot
of implications on both of those
now the first thing is the location and
the emphasis on local
and this has been increasing over the
past few years mainly there's and i'm
gonna go into a little bit of the
background why this is
now show of hands in the chat how many
of you remember when the internet made
noise that when you logged on there was
this terrible screeching beeping noise
that went on through the modem how many
of you remember that
i'm gonna look at the chat here and see
how many yeah yeah we've got a couple
yeah yeah this kind of helps me date the
audience and and know how long some of
you have been online
absolutely yeah so now think if you
could remember back to those days when
you had to
log on through a modem and you heard the
screeching noise if you remember those
days
you'll know that you only had a certain
amount of time
maybe 20 hours a month
maybe 10 hours a month but you had a
limited time budget based on how long
you could be online and you had to buy
hours or something like that and so
because there was a limited amount of
time when you sat down on that old pc
and you got online
you checked your mail you did the
searches you needed to do you checked a
couple of things and you then got logged
off and you were off the internet
and so because of that time budget it
affected your behavior as to how long
you would spend on websites how long you
would spend online
well then some of you might remember the
the transition to broadband
now we don't have to log in through the
telephone modem anymore
we can just plug in to the back of our
computer and we're always on
and think about how that changed your
behavior
you went from a time budget to now it's
always on
so now as you walk by your computer you
can just walk over and check your email
anytime during the day without having to
log on you can go to websites and spend
time you can leave it on
because it's always there and it changed
your behavior
well now we went through another drastic
behavior change
not only is the internet always on it's
now always with you
through a mobile device you now carry
around everything that you used to do
there's no time budget it's always there
and because it's mobile it has now
changed your behavior maybe recently
you've sat and thought about how much
that little device has changed your
behavior and your thinking just in the
past few years it's amazing how
smartphone devices have changed how we
go about our day how we go about
business whereas 10 years ago we would
have never imagined that our lives would
change this much
so think about the progressions of how
the technology has changed our behavior
both in business culturally and
individually
because that is why google is adjusting
the way they are and there are three
primary emerging behaviors
based on the influence of smartphone
technology on our lives
number one
we are searching for more decisions than
ever before
before we make any kind of decision we
are going and searching and
now we've always done this that's always
been a behavior of search
but now what we find is people are
searching for decisions
big and small
uh everything from what kind of shampoo
should i use to uh you know as you can
see here what were the best movies as
you can tell during the pandemic i think
people have been at home so they're
looking for the best movies
they're also searching for mattresses uh
you know best translators trading apps
best series video editing but also we
see this increase in how people search
such as uh increase in people searching
for the best an 80 increase over the
past couple of years
a six times increase in things to do and
of course with the pandemic menus are
shooting up but what's interesting
is the best dating app is increasing
dramatically so what's happening is we
are searching for more and more
relying on the search engine
to give us information we need to make a
decision both big decisions and small
decisions
now the second thing is we're demanding
personalization
we want personalization we want
personalized results based on who we are
and that's why we're now we're seeing
like i mentioned before what kind of
shampoo is best for me that is a typical
search term or what kind of uh
food what kind of diet should i be on
it's people are putting on very limited
information but expecting an amount of
personalization
now i always find this kind of humorous
because everyone wants to be an
individual and is searching for
something good for them but at the same
time when i go look and see what people
are doing they tend to be doing what
everybody else is doing we're not always
as individual as we think this is a
great instagram channel called insta
repeat and it shows how everyone's doing
the exact same thing the same poses the
same places
nothing's new everyone's just repeating
what everyone else is doing even though
we want personalization
and then also
through that personalization
this is the emphasis on local that is
increasing dramatically because of our
smartphone behavior i went through and i
looked at just some of the you know
what's near me searches uh obviously in
most countries
the number one search or the number one
group of keywords that people are
searching near me is coveted testing and
covet vaccines uh but then also i find
it interesting in the u.s boba tea is
one of the top searches uh people are
looking for boba tea near me
they're looking for hiking trails
jamaican food has made an impact somehow
bike shops and puppies
that's what people in the us are
searching for near me now i find it
interesting in the uk
uh they're looking for post boxes
financial consultants and mcdonald's
near them
and also car parts and takeaway but
whereas in india what i'm finding is
wi-fi
kia showroom uh ayurvedic shops and
akshaya center so it's it's interesting
to see in the different countries like i
i'm i'm interested to see because like
in the us people are searching for
jamaican food in the uk they're looking
for mcdonald's in india uh it's the um
i'm trying to think that um
oh there was a
there was food that was showing up there
and i can't remember what it was and in
japan it's burger king uh and pet shops
and laundromats so it's it's interesting
to see just
basically by country and i'm sure if you
look in different regions you'd see more
influence but i thought that would be a
great way just to kind of show how
people regionally are looking for things
near them and they're relying on search
to show them what's around
now here's the third behavior remember
number one is searching for decisions
people are searching for decisions big
and small number two people are
demanding personalization
three
people are becoming more impatient than
ever before because they're making
decisions faster than they've ever made
them before
and so as a result we have what we call
the fluid consumer and that is the fluid
consumer expects your website and your
app to work wherever they are on
whatever device they're using
through whatever channel they find you
in any format and it needs to work now
that is the fluid consumer
very demanding very impatient and if
your site your app your uh anything
within your social uh activity doesn't
work they have no patience for it and so
they're moving on
so those are three emerging behaviors
that are being influenced by
our smartphone culture
now because of that google is seeing how
we use smartphones and the rise of
the types of searches that are done on
smartphones and most of them revolve
around
local
searches
here's something i'd like you to do pick
up your phone and look go pick up your
phone go to a web browser and type in my
activity
dot google dot com
that's my activity dot google dot com
now if you're if you have a google
account i i should preface it with that
uh if you have a google account which
i'm assuming most of you do
you're going to see your activity on
google
for the past few months listed by day
every search that you've made
every video that you've watched
also if you're using google maps every
destination that you have mapped in
google maps
uh and so now i will say this if you're
on an iphone
that's about all you'll see
however if you're on an android phone uh
you're using google android as your
operating system you're going to see a
lot more information listed in your
activity
you're going to see what music you
listen to you're going to see any
contacts that you've called or what's
been going on and that's because of
android it's tied into google and any
app that you've got installed and how
you use the app when you use the app
what music you listen to through the app
is all going to be listed into your
activity
has anyone done this what what uh i
would love to know your reaction to
seeing your activity in google
is anyone surprised by what you've seen
or maybe a little
yeah maybe a little yeah i would say
borderline between amazement and ooh oh
no
okay yeah we've got some
some are surprised yeah yeah sylvia yeah
they're following us absolutely
so rob didn't realize is yeah they used
google that much yeah
[Laughter]
oh no
uh by the way saswadi uh using incognito
doesn't change anything
using incognito
does not mean that google does not track
what you're doing
read the terms of service of incognito
mode and all it means is that they don't
keep the cookies from the session
meaning that incognito does not keep
third-party cookies
so incognito doesn't hide you from
google especially if you're using an
android phone
because that is uh now okay great great
questions i'm seeing a lot of things
here um is this invading your privacy
not be
if you signed up for a google account
you agreed to the terms of service
this is the terms of service that google
can track your activity
not only can they track your activity
but they can share it with third-party
advertisers
people who want to bid on reaching you
and getting their ads in front of you
so
yeah this and this is the thing and and
someone made it here someone made the
point here
yes we all know that google is tracking
us we all know that
but when you see it
and you see how much data they have and
this is just the data they're showing
you
it's a bit disconcerting it's a bit
uncomfortable even though we know it's
happening
it's uncomfortable so you can also uh
get into there and by the way you you
can get into the account uh you can
limit how much google is tracking you
you can limit uh some things there
now
whether you putting limits on that
actually limits what they see and what
they track
that's a good question
but uh i will say this when we agreed to
create a google account
this was terms of service so they are
not invading your privacy same thing
when you use an if you're using an
android phone and you download an app
from the android store that app has to
integrate with the android operating
system and gives google an open window
into how you use that app and that is
all agreed to in the terms of service
that you signed up for
so
great great questions and i hope uh yeah
someone's
some of you have reacted quite strongly
there and i hope this helps and i'm
going to show you a couple other things
here as well as we go along all right
now
the reason why
google is focusing on local and language
is because it's driven by our mobile
behavior
you think about it 10 years ago
mobile was really it was really just
starting in and really it was kind of
like your business people had mobile um
and and then it became affordable and
everyone's got mobile and even the kids
have mobile now
you know so it's it's almost everyone
has a mobile phone so think about the
dramatic increase in data that's being
that's
happening
you know those of you that looked at
your activity how much of that is driven
by your mobile behavior
80
50
how much of that is happening on your
mobile and now think about it just 10 15
years ago the majority of data was from
what you did on your desktop
during while you were online
now everything you do on that mobile is
being tracked and recorded and so google
has a lot more data to deal with and now
they can start reacting to this so
google mobile has dramatically increased
the amount of data available
all right now when we look at our uh
search results and i'm going to search
for you know auto insurance or car
insurance it's a great way to get a
sense of what's happening because right
at the top of the results you're going
to get ads
then you are going to get local business
listings and this has become a
big big part of the search results
you're going to see more and more local
listings and what's interesting is i did
not search for now my search here was
for home
auto
insurance
now i did not search for near me
but google knows where i am by my ip
address if i'm on my desktop it's by my
location if i'm on my phone so i don't
always have to use near me in the search
google knows where you are
for some reason everyone seems to think
adding near me will increase the
relevance but it does not
uh it simply uh
you know is a search key phrase for
google to use but google is naturally
going to customize the results based on
your location
then we have our knowledge graph and
these are additional questions and
finally at the bottom here we get to our
organic search results and so as you can
see the results are having more and more
influence based on location
now local influence has three areas that
will help you increase your relevance
for your local influence number one it's
your actual location we know that number
two it's relevance how relevant
is your business or your content to the
search and number three is the authority
what's the authority of your website in
gaining though that visibility so very
similar in seo this should not be a
surprise well number one is location and
location here's the number one thing
that you can do
to improve your location
uh relevance and your location ability
in google and that is to make sure that
you have tied down
the nap name address and phone
you need to have a consistent address
format
and this is if you don't have consistent
address formats across different social
accounts or business accounts or google
or post anything like that
then what happens is it looks like
different businesses in different
locations
the more consistent your business
address is the more consistent it is
according to a postal service format
this is one thing i highly recommend is
look and see what the postal service
format is
for your address and then go out and
make sure that every place your address
is listed on your website on other
websites on business directories social
accounts
everywhere
make sure that your
address is consistent
where things go wrong is typically like
directions like we've got three examples
here nw northwest and northwest as two
words with capitalized
those look like three different
uh directionals and so if you have
those mixed around in different formats
it does not present a consistent address
format we see the same thing like sweet
numbers sweet three and abbreviated
things like that it can change and so
the more consistent this is the more
your location is consistent and it will
be read by google and the more
consistent it is the easier it is for
google to determine location
now here's what i love relevance now
relevance is determined if you're doing
seo you're making content you're
creating content and you're creating
relevant content you're using keywords
and this is where i love looking at
google my business for local results for
local businesses
and this report here how customers
search for your business
this is what tells you if your relevance
is increasing in your local area and
that is the discovery
all right now the yellow the yellow is
all branded
and if people are finding me for my
branded term i'm glad about that i'm
happy about that but it means that
people have to know me they're typing in
my brand name in order to find me
same thing with direct um that they're
looking for the business name or the
business address okay and they're just
going directly there now if i see that
branded and direct is less than 50
percent of my overall searches
i'm really happy because the bigger this
blue bar is
the bigger the discovery portion is it
means people are searching for general
keywords about the product about the
service they don't know the business
name they're searching for what they
need and the bigger that blue bar is it
means more people are finding me for
general search terms
which means i'm producing relevant
content
and google is associating my relevant
content with their search and it's
increasing my local visibility so that's
one of the easiest ways to find out like
a temperature check to see how relevant
your site is by looking at how many
people are finding you through a
discovery search of products or services
next is authority
an authority um someone asked where this
data is it is in google my business so
if you have a local business
go make sure it's listed or claimed on
google
and you'll be able to see this data
now authority this is the third level
authority is from links
mentions
uh reviews
and also how active you are in google my
business and on google my business you
can create posts so the same way if you
have a website with a blog and you're
making posts you can do it in a in a a
scaled down version on google my
business and so look around for your
local citations local listings business
directories do you have links in all
these areas that show that you are
integrated into the community in this
local area
but also reviews are a huge part
of local authority are people leaving
reviews either on your site or through
google through yelp through other third
parties the more reviews you have the
more it increases that local authority
and that's one of the ranking signals
for google
all right in a survey of seo experts
around the world
uh just to find out what were the key
local ranking factors uh and and again
most of our searches tend to be local
the more you rely on that phone the more
you're doing localized searches and and
hopefully looking at your activity you
realize how much you rely on your phone
you rely on google to help you find
places locally
so now to increase your local capability
uh
the experts it all came down that about
25
of your local influence was from your
google my business account so again if
you have a local business go claim that
and and go be active in it i tell people
you need to look at it at least
monthly
if you're getting a lot of interaction
then you need to look at it weekly uh
and take advantage of all the things
that you can do on google my business
but also what's important is links
reviews and on-page seo that is probably
about 45
of what influences your local visibility
um and then we get here to we probably
got another 30 which is broken up across
uh citations on other websites
personalization uh behavioral means that
uh you know they were looking for this
type of information and and social
indicators here are really kind of small
so those are the things that you can do
if you just do google my business some
seo and build reviews those are three
powerful things that you can do to
increase your local presence
all right uh we've got a quick poll here
in the middle and uh i would like to
know maybe look look back at your
activity and how many local searches
would you estimate that you make in a
week
uh one to five five to ten
stuart if you could put up the poll
there great love it i would like to know
you know if you remember your history or
maybe you need to go back and take a
look at it
how many searches do you make in a week
local searches let me say that
stuart i can't see the results of that
can you see that
oh there we go
wow wow
i expected the you know six to ten to
perform but yeah almost a fourth of you
are over 20 uh a week
yeah with isn't that amazing how much it
has changed our behavior
over the years
fantastic all right now let's look at
the second half so the first half was
all about localization and because of
the increase of how we use our phones to
rely on google
to find local things
now let's start looking at the language
the language is a completely different
aspect of this but because of the
increase of searches
every year google gets more and more
searches and even google has said that
there's a good percentage of searches
every year
that they've never seen before
and that is amazing to me that every day
there are searches being made and it's
literally the first time that search has
ever been made on google
and so a lot of times those types of
searches
they don't always have an easy answer
and so google has been investing heavily
in language products and language
research
to find out how to better understand
some of these searches
and provide results
now
one of these was burt
bert is a
as and i like that it's it's it's short
for bi-directional encoder
representations
uh google likes to play around with
these names in order to uh
name what it is and what simply what
bird is all about is there's a lot of
nuance to language
and that nuance takes place in how we
use words
now and those of you you know if english
is your second language you probably or
your third language you probably know
how difficult a language english is
i you know there are so many words like
this
the word like
now how is the word like used
i like coffee i you know some of you
probably seen i i love coffee um now i
can also say this coffee tastes like
dirt
or i feel
like a movie star my friend and i are
alike it's like you know just how what
are the ways we use that word and now
how is a computer supposed to interpret
that word when it's being used in a
search query because it has so many
applications
that are not the same and that's one of
the things that every language has this
i think english probably just has more
it's just more of a frustrating language
um and so
a lot of these language algorithms are
attempting to figure this out um and and
this is what also another aspect of our
behavior
that google's trying to figure out is
when we need to describe something
and we don't know what it is
and this is called keyword foraging
keyword foraging is
when i need something but i don't know
what it's called
or uh you know a great example is my
wife who know who's trying to find an
actor when she's watching a television
show and she can't remember their name
but she thinks she knows what movie
they're in and she's trying to describe
who this actor is in the search bar and
that's called keyword foraging is when
i'm using search to find the word with
which i will then do my actual search
hopefully i explain that well it's when
we don't know the word also if there are
dialectic differences uh they're you
know a difference you know in in england
uh
you know in in the us we call it an
elevator in england it's called a lift
uh and then also uh i i love watching
the british uh bake off and they have
different words caster sugar uh and we
would call that powdered sugar there's
different words and i'm not always sure
you know what's the word for this if i'm
trying to do a recipe i need to know
what that is so that i know how to
search for it
also
and this happens more times is if i need
a solution
but i don't know what it is
and so i'm trying to describe my problem
and this happens a lot if you've ever
had to troubleshoot anything that's
wrong with your computer or a printer or
something with your network
you don't know what the solution is and
somehow we have to describe the problem
in a way
that we get good search results which is
very difficult
and so we describe things we describe
what it looks like or one of the things
and this was very interesting from a
test subject
who was being observed in how they
search and one of the things they said
is especially in fashion
in fashion
you have to know the name of something
before you can go look for it
the example she gave is
she wanted something that was called a
long sweater
and that's all she knew is long sweater
uh and all she knew was it was like a
cardigan but it's long and she said
especially in fashion you have to know
the words
and it makes it very very difficult to
actually search for the product you want
when you don't know what it is but you
can describe it
now
from an seo standpoint what does this
tell us
this tells us we need to get better at
describing our products
how would people search for your product
if they don't know what the name is
or don't know the technical words for it
how would they describe it if they were
looking for it and so enabling that and
adding that in into your content will
enable you to be found for it but google
actually is trying to figure this out
so that they understand what people are
searching for
in order to direct them to the right
place and maybe save then that second
search for when they know the word
all right now one of the latest
technologies google has started
implementing is called mum
multitask unified model
it doesn't really mean anything
basically what they're saying is this is
one thousand times more powerful than
burnt and what it's looking for is
complex queries complex searches that
have no simple answer
and also
being able to draw information from
other languages
so there they've got 75 languages that
they're working on right now that if i
search for something a great example
would be if i want to um
you know if i i'm trying to think what
would be you know something i want to do
um you know if i wanted to go hiking uh
across
a certain mountain range or something
like that what would i need
there's no simple answer to that
however
what google would be able to do what
their target is
is it would pull information from other
people who have been there and blogged
about it and took pictures of it
as well as their information
it would translate any information from
another language website or another
language blog
and it would give me the information i
need to determine what do i need in
order to hike that mountain range or to
to go to that location
and also
it is pulling information from video
text information it's also pulling data
and information from images
one of the examples google gave was
uploading a picture of a pair of shoes
saying are these shoes good enough to
run a marathon
what kind of a search is that
what google is encouraging is some
amazingly creative searches
so that if you take a picture of a pair
of running shoes and ask can i run the
new york city marathon in these shoes
google's going to give you an answer and
that answer is going to be pulled from
other experts
other websites and other websites and
other languages in order to provide you
an answer
so this is what google is doing with
language is
uh you know and and i have to say
i love
language i'm fascinated by language this
is just exciting to me what's happening
from a technology standpoint
from an seo standpoint
things are getting a bit weird all right
and here's where
this is going and after this poll i'm
going to get into how as an seo we have
to react to this
all right last poll i would love to know
what marketing skills you're most
interested in learning
so i wanted to thank you all for
attending this webinar uh we're
coming in i will finish up this section
and then we can do some q a um so thank
you all for making the time to attend
this webinar and i hope already it's
been a little enlightening uh and some
of you i think maybe have some work to
do to go back to your activity settings
in google
all right
the poll is closed
and yeah seo by far up at that 62
yes uh seo content marketing social
media yeah those three are typically the
top three and really happy to see that
fantastic
great
all right now let's look at the
implications for seo based on location
we already talked about what you can do
to increase location but what is all
this language technology doing to us as
seos
there's a huge impact on keywords
this is where everything starts now i
love working in keywords and i'm one of
those who if you remember when we used
to be able to see the keywords people
used to come to our website
i long for those days oh please could i
see my keywords again
but that was the first step google made
in hiding keyword data
they didn't want us the seo the website
owner to see the keyword data that was
driving people to our site
i think a large part it was because that
people were keying on certain words and
focusing on that word because that
word's producing sales that word is
doing things and so i'm going to focus
on that and i think google knew that if
they took away keywords that it would
take away our ability to focus on these
terms
and then also google was allowing you to
receive keywords if you were doing paid
search and you could see the words
people made if you were paying
through the ads but then they started
taking that away and so more and more
google is hiding all of the keyword data
in in behind their walls and they're not
sharing it
and you've probably seen this this is
the most frustrating thing at all to see
in your analytics and that is keyword
not provided
yeah why why is this happening
let me tell you why this is what's going
on um
now if you've done any keyword research
you might have seen this this part i was
gonna do live but i said it's just it's
just gonna be quicker to do this with
screenshots
if i use a keyword tool like word
tracker and i type in something like
summer camp summer camps
look at this i get 4 000 keyword
suggestions all right 4 000 keyword
suggestions and then i'm seeing volumes
monthly volumes in the thousands
if i do the same search on google's
keyword tool look what they give me
one keyword
i'm not seeing the variations i'm not
seeing adventure camp in california uh
i'm not seeing you know we've got 4 000
variations here but according to google
there's only one term
wow
well that's not unique
look at it here
if i search for a couch
and i ask google to give me some keyword
ideas i get two i get sofa and i get
couch depending upon your what you call
it but here if i go to word tracker i
get 5 000 keyword suggestions
5 000
and i'm also seeing the volume amounts
look at this so 14 000 thousand eight
thousand okay look what hap look what
google gives me
one million to ten million for these two
terms
does something seem off here
yeah google is not sharing data
google is taking all these keywords as
you can see 5 000 variations and by the
way word tracker stops at 5 000.
so they're taking 5000 different keyword
suggestions and what they're giving you
are two
they're boiling it all down to the core
phrase
and that's what they want you to bid on
if you're doing paid search
they want you to bid on this keyword
that drives close to 1 million visits
this keyword you know drives even more
and what they're telling you is let us
figure it out
rather than you because those of you
that do paid search you know you're
getting keywords you're doing uh you're
matching them to certain search phrases
to the phrase match the broad match
things like that
and they're asking you to let them
manage
all of these combinations let's look at
a couple if i look for auto body shop uh
you know this is a local search
something some you know i need to get
something fixed in my car i have 1400
keyword suggestions google gives me one
looking for a doctor
ah look at all this
i've got all kinds of doctor searches
google gives me two family doctor family
practice doctor
this is for almost everything
pool table and i have cheap pool tables
pool table light coin operated pool
tables and in here's what's frustrating
these i have
4 500 keyword suggestions for a pool
table
and they each look at these they
describe different things
like a light or lighting that is
completely different than coin operated
completely different they're two
different things but google is saying
one keyword
wow
yeah this is google keyword planner this
is what google is is is providing you
so
yeah in one way google's making it
simpler but what's happening
and what's happening is google is taking
all the plurals and they're merging them
together
anything that has acronyms they're
putting it together any variants
um like place location
uh features it's all coming down
anything that has spaces or hyphens or
anything google is combining all of that
so they're taking like the the 5 000
variations
i'm bringing it down to one maybe two
keywords
and what they're saying is you know
i'm doing my research and i'm finding
that
and what google is saying is these two
are only you need
you know especially for paid search
that's what's happening
now
this here's what here's what's going on
is that google is only letting you see
a tiny bit of the keyword universe
they don't want you to see everything
they are going to manage this they're
going to hold it and control it and this
has everything to do with control
everything to do with the control of
search and the control of
this is their plans for 20 years in the
future this has everything to do
by the way
google
80
of their revenue comes from ads
okay
80
of their money comes from ads
so all of this
think about it
what they don't care what goes on with
seos because we don't make a money all
right
what makes them money
are ads and so a lot of this keyword
data is being focused and to understand
how to get more people to click on more
ads because that's what makes money all
right so from an seo standpoint they're
only going to show us a tiny little bit
of a keyword universe
here's what's happening like i said so
we've got you know
5000 keyword variations
down here we're seeing you know one to
two keywords
that now what google wants you to do
in a paid search
they want you to bid on those terms
and of course anyone who's doing paid
search is saying no way i'm not doing
that
i'm going to use matching i'm going to
find the keywords that i absolutely need
here and i'm going to use those and i'm
going to match them but if you go set up
a paid search account right now you
don't get the tools to do that
now what's happening in here
all right this is google's
machine learning
and all in this is where you know bert
and mom
are really taking the task
what they are doing is they are saying
everything between here and here is
theirs
they will determine
relevance
intent
location
motivation
they will determine that
from these variations
and based on that
they will determine if it's relevant for
your website
that's what they're going to do
is you will have optimized your now
hopefully you're taking these 5000
variations and you're applying them into
your website you're creating articles
about what people want to know and how
to you know and you're doing the seo and
that's the only thing you can do
you take these variations and you apply
that to the content on your
website google is creating a walled
garden where no one can see what the
processing is behind the scenes
of
what people search for and so when
someone makes that search they're going
to apply their language and their
machine learning now what's that machine
learning but also based on
history
that's the big one
okay
that's the big one your search history
everything that you just looked at in my
activity all those searches all those
videos you watched all the locations you
had the kind of music you listened to
what google is doing is they are putting
you into segments
and so you as a consumer are being
segmented into hundreds of interest
segments based on your history
so now when you do a search you go into
this keyword universe
and google is applying all their machine
learning language algorithms to your
search
and they're matching it to your history
and what have you searched for before
what have you bought recently where have
you been recently and they will adjust
the search to
you
and give you those results more
personalized than ever based on your
activity
they want to do the same thing in paid
search and what this does is it becomes
much more if anyone's been doing paid
search for years this is very
aggravating but what they are telling
business owners is you bid on those one
to two keywords
and you let us
handle who's relevant and who's not and
we'll deliver relevant traffic to you
i don't like that i really don't
i don't really trust google to do that i
want to manage that myself i want to do
it and it's a complicated process
and so when google is telling an average
business owner you just set up a budget
tell us what business you're in and
we'll take care of the rest it sounds
good but that's how they're doing it is
they are processing all these searches
that are made
and
not allowing anyone really to see behind
the curtain of what's going on and
that's how they are going to manage all
of this
so more than ever
you need to rely on keyword research
tools and when i do this i i went
through this last time and just to kind
of give you an overview of what i do
from this is number one you look at this
i have 5 000 keywords for insurance all
right i know there's more so i can dig
in and even get more and i'm going to
export all those keywords typically what
i'll do is i'll export it into
uh
excel
and that way i can look at it and
manipulate it within the excel tables i
can see what keyword there is the volume
i can get some competition and things
like that uh and i start now reviewing
all those keywords and what i will do
from there is then i will theme the
keywords i will cluster them according
to
different factors
again location
features
timing intent
i will take all those keywords the 5 000
keywords that i got out of here and i
start looking to see what is
what are the themes that i can derive so
i can look for synonyms people use the
word auto and car interchangeably
however car is used three times more
than auto if you're an seo that should
be blowing your mind because now that
guides you as to how you should optimize
that you should use the word car three
times more than auto
but now let's look at some themes some
clusters you can make out of the
keywords
people when they search for insurance
they search based on cost and i see
words like cheap inexpensive low rates
discount how much those are all
cost-based keywords and so i can cluster
these words
and now when i create my content i if
i'm creating content
for people who are looking for low-cost
insurance i now have a whole group of
words that i can pull from and use in my
content
same thing if i have different product
types if i have insurance for classic
cars if i have insurance for high risk
or a new car or an antique car
this tells me people are searching for
it so now i can go create content for it
it gives me a map to follow uh now also
another theme is comparison
people compare so they're looking for
the best insurance or how to compare
insurance what's the average cost what's
local what's nearby and so i can take
that into account and when i'm looking
at how to compare insurance anything
like that and then i can develop content
along these
themes building these themes will make
me more relevant for google's language
processing because they're theming as
well and the more i do it the more it
matches how they are processing this
language
all right i've gone a little bit longer
than i planned here uh but i was having
a lot of fun with you so we've got a few
minutes left and i can answer some
questions
stuart
yeah we've got some some very
interesting questions from the audience
i'm sure we won't have time to take all
of them but i wanted to ask
from vegeron is virtual reality going to
play part in search engine results in
future
that's a great great question i don't
see it happening right away um
you know i'm doing some work in virtual
reality right now and it's going to be a
hard
transition and the main reason why is
because it requires an additional device
uh the and what that is it's a
gatekeeping device
uh a great example is is qr codes qr
codes came out 10 years ago nobody knew
how to use them and not only that no
one's phone
had a native application that would read
it
and so you had to download a qr code
reader to use the qr code and now
because of the pandemic
did you notice your phone naturally has
a qr code reader you just take a picture
so now a 10 year old technology is now
in a place where everyone can use it and
everyone knows what it was
or everyone knows what it is so it's the
same thing with virtual reality we have
a physical obstacle i think when that
obstacle is removed and it becomes much
more a part of your life that's when
we'll see it really making an impact
great
um
now i asked a really good question you
talked about
how
[Music]
users are impatient and want everything
now how how do marketers
use that impatience in their favor
um part of that a great great question i
saw this the other day when someone was
talking about building a customer
journey
and they were talking about the buying
cycle and the buying process and what
was missing and and in fact they made
the statement that no one wakes up in
the morning and says i want to buy that
and and i had to disagree
because that happens all the time
people are unpredictable and so i need
to give them a path i need to create
content and a path for those people that
you know it they just want it right now
they don't care what the content is so i
need to give them a direct path to do
that and maybe that's you know whether
it's the content maybe it's the function
i need to allow people to go right to
what they want regardless of i may have
a whole journey i may have a whole path
set up i need to give some shortcuts too
yeah and this is why in american
supermarkets they play all the candy
right next to the checkout stand that's
right that's right
i want that
impulse um
aj asks if google is getting rid of
cookies soon
they said they were um they said they
were going to do that they backed off of
that and they backed off because they
were going to use a different technology
called flock and that is federated
learning of cohorts
and what that was is as a chrome user
based on the websites you visit they
would put you in a specific segment
and so advertisers could bid and put ads
to that segment
it's not a perfect solution in fact it's
very imperfect
and what happened was because in google
doing this it's a power play in the ad
tech industry and they are consolidating
all of the data to themselves and as a
result amazon said we are not going to
support flock in fact we will block
that ability
uh
on our amazon sites wordpress
uh came out and now wordpress sites make
up over forty percent of the internet uh
of websites on the internet and
wordpress developers said i think we're
gonna block flock too
joomla drupal um
other search engines so many people in
the internet industry came out and said
we're blocking what google's doing
um and so google backed off and they
have given cookies a reprieve so we
don't know
now when those third-party cookies are
going to go away
okay
um
cushy asks
does google's algorithm change by
country
um
there well let's put okay let's let's
answer one big question google's
algorithm changes daily
so
that's one question it changes all the
time
um now the algorithms it would be more i
think based on language
that there would be different they would
be applying the same algorithm but it
might apply differently based on the
language um and then for certain
countries google does do work with
different governments and so there are
some restrictions in for example in
europe where you can't show certain
content for sale and so
it's more of just kind of like an
addendum to the algorithm rather than um
you know you know exactly what's going
on with that that's uh
that's kind of what we're looking at
there
so it's slightly uh but it's more
language based
okay
speaking of language uh kanye
asks if there's
any scope or effect from
tribal or regional languages
um
there is um
that is what uh google is trying to do i
mean they're like i said right now it's
it's 75 languages that they're they're
using in
uh
and trying to deal with this uh but they
are i think they're well over 200
languages or something that they're
actually working with
um
now what's interesting is i i'm waiting
to see how google can build a a more
humanitarian application
that would be very beneficial rather it
seems like they're holding all this in
they're not sharing it and there's a lot
that could be done to help people um and
and that's the one thing that really
really concerns me about
their investment in language is that
they're not sharing it really with the
world
um
i have a couple of questions
i'll ask simultaneously because they
both deal with
location
hamani asks about
what to do if he's an online business
who serves four or five cities so it has
four or five locations
and sophia asks
what about businesses that don't have
any physical address that are just
online
all right if you have multiple locations
you can do a different google my
business for each location
uh and so you can develop that and then
also you can set i believe an
administrator over that so that you can
claim those um you can still use now if
you are a local business but you don't
have a physical presence that's a little
more difficult uh google
google my business is developed for more
location-based businesses
um
you can try and build that but if you
service more like kind of like if you're
a remote worker and i can do you know
anything anywhere
um
you know it might be a little more
difficult you may want to see if you can
do it because some businesses you don't
have to put in an address
but they do want to know your physical
address so it could help increase your
local presence if you want to sell
locally okay i i want to close with just
one quick question from raju who asks
what type of preparation
would you recommend for somebody who
wants to get ready for
applying for a job at google wow um i'll
tell you what read as much as you can
about what they're doing in technology
think about what area you want to be in
do you want to be in research do you
want to be an algorithm you know what
part of google do you want to work in
and and be prepared read as much as you
can find out what's happening see the
different areas that are there uh
because if you go in with saying i want
to learn more about this and i want to
contribute here and you're very specific
that that will be part of that
great that's great advice and
it's time for us to wrap up i apologize
to anybody who's questions we couldn't
take
as matt as shown on the screen
you can track him down at
these different social media handles
matt bailey asl at linden
his endless coffee cup podcast why don't
you tell the audience about what that is
yeah so i have created a podcast really
to follow up with those of you that have
taken my classes on simplylearn uh those
of you that maybe have seen me in
different areas and i maybe even have
met you here or there but i created the
podcast as a follow-up to anyone who's
taken my classes online
it's a way to get some better
information about what's going on in the
marketing world how that affects us
culturally in fact one of the last uh
class or one of the last uh podcasts we
did was about six myths about seo that
won't go away and we do talk about some
of the language processing that's there
but if you follow the the bitly link uh
i highly recommend the six seo myths uh
as a great follow-up to today's session
because that will uh i should get the
direct link but i can't get off my
desktop here so that's
uh but that's uh that's one of the most
recent podcasts i highly recommend it
and then there's a link to the book
teach new dogs old tricks
perfect
um i'm going to leave that up for just a
second
while i put the
links into the
chat
and there you go
so you have the links to matt's podcast
and advanced book and
with that i'm going to take back sharing
that
all right
and
i want
to thank you for being here i want to
thank
all of our attendees i'm going to
mention a couple of
final things
real quick we do have and i've dropped a
link into the
chat
at least once but
a postgraduate program in digital
marketing
and this is a comprehensive program that
covers
all of the skills of digital marketing
provides you
a certain certificate from purdue
university
and access to the purdue alumni
association
and it's a
great program
takes five to ten hours a week and
i believe it's a six-month program and
it's a really good way to
get to the upper echelon of a digital
marketing career of course we have a
number of other
marketing programs so if you want to
just study a specific
skill
you have the ability to do that
but i will drop that into the chat and
hold on a moment
so i wait for the chat to come back
the last thing i'd like to announce is
our next webinar which is next tuesday
less than a week from now but this is a
career webinar with the head of
hr at big basket a
big e-commerce firm in india tian hari
and he is both a
venture capitalist and
an executive and he will talk about the
subject of his latest book which is the
role of jew god in building your career
to god being
thriftiness and economy and and making
do and he'll talk about when
you want to be
thrifty and economical in pursuing your
career and when's the right time
to make that big investment in yourself
so
it's going to be a very interesting uh
session i will also drop that into the
chat
i love that idea i
i gotta so early in my career in seo it
was all about the free tools and i can
list them off probably the top 20 free
tools and i still use some of them today
um so i love that concept i think that
is so perfect and uh yeah it is great
and
uh as hari says the the
the big trend in um
startups
especially in india is
the idea that you should do everything
on a shoestring and apply jakod in all
situations and
his thesis is that in startups and in
your personal career
there are times when you want to say no
to you god which is the title of his
book so
thank you all very much and thank you
especially matt for being here and
giving a
very
interesting
um
webinar
that covered
in depth some really important topics um
the
comments we've been seeing in the chat
have been
really really um appreciative so
with that uh we're gonna we're gonna end
the webinar um you can
track down simple learn on our social
media
at simplylearn on facebook and twitter
simplylearn on linkedin
and we look forward
to not only seeing you at future
webinars but welcoming into
the simply learn learner community all
of you who want to pursue your digital
marketing career further
thank you again and
this concludes the webinar
okay
it